hello everyone welcome to our session on
data governance as some of you may
remember back in November in London we
had announced our partnership and today
I'm delighted to be with Jim again to
talk about our progress today let's take
a look at recent goldman sachs ports
security breaches data loss legal and
compliance issues are slowing down many
in their mood to public-house
fundamentally they're worried about loss
of control when you look at bigquery it
was designed as a cloud native data
warehouse it was designed to address the
needs of an enduring organization in a
cloud first world with its reliability
security and its governments so what is
data governance and why it matters data
governance is a strategic part of an
organization that sets in place policies
and procedures to maximize utilization
and value data for decisions and
operations while ensuring data quality
standards privacy standards security
controls and regulatory compliance gcpd
provides robust tools and technology to
protect and govern your throughout the
lifecycle of the data we offer built-in
protectionist scale buying defaults data
is automatically encrypted while and
transits and interests we supply tools
and technology to efficiently govern all
your data for example cloud DLP helps
you discover and classify sensitive data
assets cloud I am provides access
control and visibility security policies
and our newly GA cloud data catalog
helps you discover and manage all your
data we support compliance requirements
with all third-party certifications
finally we believe that the trust is
created through transparency and for
that we provide truly
access transparency which gives you the
visibility and accesses by either the
support teams or the engineering teams
at all times let's talk about some of
the enhancements that we've done around
daily classes and fine-grain apples now
with bigquery's called echo control you
can start thinking about data as a set
of data classes some more sensitive than
others data catalogue will control
policies per data class
audit logs will refer to these data
classes let's take a look at it in a
deeper level and the use case you say
the Calif to define a taxonomy of policy
tags and an access permissions for users
groups apply these policy tags to
bigquery columns in this example you may
have first responders they may need to
have access to some of the BIA
information like location and phone and
so forth or in the other hand auditors
would have additional access to maybe
financial information now you'll be able
to provide all these controls very
easily on GCP we provide a platform
that's end-to-end government you can
imagine looks like two zones and free
zone where not much of the sensitive
data is really a presence but a govern
zone where a lot of your government data
needs are pricey past couple of years we
have been focusing on building the
best-in-class capabilities for you to
achieve better governs own to be
querying for all your enterprise needs
by establishing fine-grain tackles
column table row levels in whatever by
integrating DLP to drive auto data
classification by introducing data
Callao to the sky discover and tag your
data however data governance is a vast
space and many of you have complex
hybrid environments as we announced last
November in London we have partnered
with Calibra the market leading
governance
is provided to help you with all your
data governance needs in this hybrid
world and I am delighted to inform
everyone that calibra is now GA on GCP
and we're working together on joint
roadmaps to further hand enhance our
offerings to everyone as we saw before
the IT catalog and mccurry allows you to
govern they had a finer granularity
through policy tanks but governance is
much more than that we also need to
apply revoke modify access in response
to events across your inner paths as I
mentioned earlier we've already begun
integrating calibra into GCP services
our catalogs are designed to work
together to help system integrate
achieve data governance for high
persistence whether it's your multi
flight needs or cloud and on-premise
with Calibra on GCP you will have the
best of the two worlds to achieve all
your data analytics and data governance
needs my partner Jim will now walk you
through Kali Brown GCP journey that's
pretty thank you everyone I really
appreciate the introduction and excited
to share with you guys a use case in
others it's been countless ways that you
can identify value from this combined
offering but we're going to settle in on
a use case defined by George he's a
business analyst working on the Google
Analytics platform and both his goal is
customer satisfaction
now that's a year-long endeavor but over
over the year he's looking for different
data sets that answer different
questions that show how customer
satisfaction is achieved maintaining it
grows then it reduces churn
so in this situation we're going to
focus on a moment in time where George
is looking for additional data beyond
what George is working with thus far to
answer some questions about customer
churn the process is going to follow
something like this and it's going to be
a use case around what we called data
from and this is a situation where
there's only a subset of data that
George currently has access to but
looking for what else might be in
so George we'll start with an example of
using Calibra to actually work on the
Google cloud to search the catalog and
once that's done our job is to help
navigate George through the shopping
experience go out and fetch the data for
George and presented back to George for
consumption so let's go ahead and jump
in so Elizabeth George start so the
first thing that George is gonna do
using this shopping metaphor is try to
find a door that open and so George
being kind of a non-technical person
might start with more of a business term
so George is gonna type in customer
churn it has to return for George's is a
definition of it's been defined in his
business glossary it is shared within
the entire company I'm not when George
first sees this and then navigate to
different facts and facets such as
picking business terms in these business
terms then that provide various things
within the glossary that George can
choose from if George chooses customer
churn it takes George to the next step
now this is like opening up a door to
our rack of information available to
George and if some of the things that
George might sees which custard which
models are actually available underneath
the definition of customer churn such as
customer order or a product some
financial metrics tags and other things
and this is a means of George basting
getting oriented in the store and
finding out where to go to next and
let's suppose George says new customer
is a really important thing I'd like
they're a little bit more about it so
one of the first things we do is show
George what is the content of customer
as a logical model and here we're
listing all of the different attributes
and fields that really make up the
definition of the canonical definition
of a customer in any one of these George
can click on one of the definitions and
learn more about them again as an asset
within the graph but again we're leaves
up to the customer domain model but
again meant to customer churn as a
business term now click might say ok
this is great I like the content here so
let me learn more so I'm gonna navigate
down the Iowa as cliff navigates down
the aisle of this kind of customer to
find I want to find various things that
are groups such as systems and within
systems
might have databases and within that
might have schemas and eventually you
get down to tables
these are catalog assets that tell cliff
about the various things that are aware
that the company is aware of that have
been classified and met to the logical
model of customer and so this kind of
gives me an inventory of ultimately what
is in this aisle that puts a shopping
known by customer but furthermore with
my links they are able to me tell me
more and this is where we show the
integration in the inheritance to a
table all the way back to policies and
rules and regulations and limitations
and reference data that make up the body
of governance that's within the cleaver
system so in this situation cliff can
see very quickly that I have a table
with in there called customer product
sales that have actually been classified
for machine learning to the customer
domain and by definition that inherits
all of the items that are
classifications and standards and
policies that you see in green
Illustrated to the left of the screen
well once cliff understands this cliff
might say ok well ok I like this but I
want to know where these products will
actually come from
what were these where these tables come
from and where they go and maybe what
happens and that's what we called
lineage this is the idea of how did the
data actually arrive at this point in
destination where else does it go after
this destination who uses it and didn't
happen to it on its destination to me
such as some type of transformation on
objects so we can actually capture all
the underlying transformation that may
have happened to this physical aspect
that you're considering for shopping
purposes since they've clicked like a
worthless stuff made was it made in the
US that made in Italy somewhere else I
would like to know as well as what
happened on with the journey along the
way
um now the next thing cliff might say is
ok I'm now down to five different items
to choose on the shelf how do i
delineate each mean how do I know which
one is right for me well that oftentimes
is being done through tribal knowledge
or what did I do in past but it's
generally not objective or defendable
and it doesn't always lead to
trustworthy information so what we offer
in the Clipper solution are highly
visible and easy visual
around a profile score and the goal is
to provide cliff very quickly kind of
front of label on the demarcation about
what is the best for what they want so
in this situation we're showing various
attributes that make their customer that
were interest of interest to George and
showing which system actually has the
best so for example the customer billing
seems to have the high score for email
whereas customer product sales has the
best information both address and for
charity since those are important it
seems like the customer product sales is
something that would be pretty important
to George now maybe that's not another
front of label some of us shoppers like
to turn the label around and if
necessary we can get some detailed
statistical information about that
column using stats are null values
anonymous values distribution
frequencies etcetera that can really
help us choose which of these data sets
to use for his analysis now click the
set ok this is the one I want I'm adding
customer products sales as you see a
little straighter than the center here
and this isn't in let's Chucky basket
now you can see there are other data
sets that were already in there let's
just assume that cliff have already
shopped for things and maybe these work
sitting in wait but the next big thing
that cliff wants to do is that you know
I'm not the buying product at the
grocery store I'm actually asking for
data and I need to ask for requests so
this starts the request process and the
each each customer can set up its own
need for how they manage this process
but also leave the data owner itself
that would grant their authorization to
this data would wonder why do you want
it how long are you gonna use it where
are you gonna use it etc and so cliff
fills out this level of information I'm
sorry George Earth enters this level of
information in the dataset requests and
one thing I'll draw your attention to is
that George is actually selected to
lease but at least is this notion of a
short term duration but I want a
physical copy of the data whereas borrow
would be an example of something I just
want to have virtualized for a very very
short period of time can buy would be
actually want to take a full copy going
forward and then ultimately might also
say where do I want to take it
we're actually going to bring a data set
to Google bigquery well of course there
are dates for how long
George would like to use it now after
George has actually submitted this
request but it needs to go over to the
data owner so we're going to switch
perspectives rather quickly and look at
Joe in there and she receives an inbound
requests from George and so you can see
the Joanne has seen the same information
that George entered in their quest and
kind of the center panel and off to the
right is where Jelena would then
determine whether she wants to grant
approval for this or not no I'm showing
you a manual version for this now
obviously for a fact but you can set up
rules and workflows that can automate
this process based on who's making the
request for what purpose for how long
and where is it going to go but this is
a you can either manually do it or you
can set up automatically but since she
actually improves this request then it's
going to go back to George and when it
comes back to George there's one last
thing that he has to do he has to
acknowledge all of the items to the
right that are part and parcel with
actually taking a Lisa of data for a
period of time to Google bigquery and
you'll remember those were established
in his green boxes earlier on when we
looked at the customer domain and they
were all inherited through them to the
dataset that cliff or George is now
asking for so once George is actually
affirmed with this request he can now
check out and so this is the really
interesting part so because again George
is not a technician we don't George
taught to do a bunch of assembly etc
we're now going to kick off a data
provisioning process and so we really
are finished up with step one here and
then the next step is that we're
actually going to have an edge based
appliance it really is close to the data
center wherever it happens to be suppose
it's on your own the plumbing premise it
could be in another flower it could be a
space solution that you're working with
there were these virtual appliance that
actually is reading back to the Google
Cloud Servers talk to the delivery guy
out and say do I have any instructions
and the instructions would be this
request that George has asked for and
received approval they would be
downloaded and they would execute a
distributed query against the underlying
days
or datasets that have been approved
after that thing is extracted it would
then be composited which is basically
the process of looking for any
duplication within that data set and
compositing it down to a golden record
choosing the best attributes from
amongst their contributors once that's
been done then we also want to
acknowledge that not one George's are
like some George's might have access to
certain data elements that others are
not and that's where we deploy this
policy enforcement around access means
we would actually eliminate data that's
not actually available for George to
look at either by Road academic or mass
commit before it's passed along to be
loaded into inquiry for the request once
that's done the data is then encrypted
transformed up to the appropriate
landing spot for bigquery and then
subsequently loaded into bigquery and
once that's been done now that one of
George is notified the dataset is ready
for processed now when the data is ready
or for processing George can do a couple
of things and look at the data kind of
in the raw directly within bigquery but
more likely George is going to want to
look at this and kind of a bi reporting
or analytic environment choice and let's
suppose it's looker and so that's
exactly how George is going to start
working with this new data set and maybe
either alone or in combination with
other data sets that were already
available to George with in big query as
well as Google catalog but work or in
combination order separately so now
George is actually been able almost
fully at the click of a button have data
provisioned for his use without having
to write any code and it's all been done
under a govern use case and so that's
really what we call data use provision
but to really round out the use case we
have to send notification and reminder
to George but you know you're just using
this data for a short period of time in
order to comply with the data use
agreement you actually have to get rid
of it when you're done with it so we
sent a notice off to to George let them
know exactly that you're out your use of
the data is expired and it's time to
really and of course then we'll notify
Joanna if the same as occurred if in
fact it's been compliant and George
didn't get rid of it otherwise we get
escalated and she would be able to
follow up accordingly to make sure that
it's they
now this is a just one of many many use
cases to follow we thought it was a good
illustration of how the combined
solution works together in a highly
relative you space in terms of where we
are today everyone's kind of to announce
that we're available on Google Cloud
as of July 6 now we are also working on
more and more tighter integration you'll
see where we are now realist Orage with
a principle of least privilege with data
class level securities available within
Google and through the integration with
calibra we also offer this ability to
shop and discover and make that request
for data in a quickly David's already in
bigquery or cloud storage they're just
asking for approval or it might actually
need to be provisioned in situations
where it actually needs to be
provisioned we'll probably not within
the next year's roadmap but I think I'd
also like to share with you back later
this year maybe by the end of the year
Libre data intelligence for your
convenience will be available on the
Google file marketplace and if you've
enjoyed what you listen to here I really
highly recommend that you follow your
other peers in the industry and even
though we just announced this a short
period of time ago we have a large
number of customers who've already
expressed interest and we're starting
that journey with us so if you would
like to follow in their footsteps please
I would suggest you follow up either the
google filed website or the Calibra
website on behalf of Aaron and myself I
would like to thank you for for joining
us as well as wish you guys safety in
these difficult times thank you